[Musik]
christa winter kauf ausbildung auf diese
toiletten für die opfer und hutchinson
nummer drei stationen das ist die
station mg und darüber ist bekämpfen von
feind im winterlichen geräte und
stellungswechsel und absätzen durch
geräte mit mg
weshalb bei der station absetzen weg das
ist defensiv war reaktionsschnell
das bedeutet dass man sie vom gegner
löst und das feuer und bewegung
diese übung wird geschossen mit dem
sturmgewehr kommando a2 welches beim
jahr kommando standardmäßig eingeführt
ist es ist klar unterscheidet sie im
wesentlichen zum gewehr von der truppe
in der lauflänge wir besitzen einen
kürzeren lauf welches die waffe führe
gemacht habe mir meine drei verfolgt von
einem hip hop sinn wenn man einen freund
so punkt wie zero für eine schnelle
zielerfassung
einen hülsen abwässer ein laserlicht
module mit einem träger zur bedienung
und 1 42 schoss magazin für einen
höheren der munitions ansatz
[Musik]
gut wir sind auf der station
scharfschießen im trupp rahmen wir haben
jetzt hat folgende situation das jahr
kommando team die ist zersprengt worden
und hat jetzt den aufdruck dass er sich
im zweierbob eben im trupp rahmen
durchschlagen zum nächsten sammelpunkt
und ich würde sagen wir steigen gleich
mal ein
[Musik]
und wenn wir das sagen hat wenn du teil
von unserem team sein will dann meldete
bei uns die kontaktdaten findet unten in
der beschreibung
[Musik]